okay everyone
hopefully through here first and you
know that had a blast law between that
late to New York's big however prejudice
wants to open comments please give a
warm welcome to the infamous generals
three DS planet Houston I am General Zod
and that time the classes will begin
very shortly but first I have a little
announcement to make
I General Zod we like to announce my
candidacy for president of the United
States there are several reasons why I
will be a good president all taxes going
to a good cause you see I plan to take
the United States of America and turn it
into a giant sculpture of myself all 50
states will take on different parts of
my body can imaginary plans force order
I also noticed that the economy is not
so hot people are having a very hard
time finding jobs well no more I say
that every single one of you will have
jobs do you think the United States of
America's culture is just going to carve
itself no the people of Florida will
work will work excuse me
the people of Florida will work
especially long and hard there is a big
thing about censorship all these old
mucky-mucks want to censor everything
that you see I say nobody will look
dressed and sound like me so really
what's there to censor all of you will
be wearing this outfit bring out women
you may want to work on growing your
beers
see some of you have already started
next the health programs in America are
despicable need to exercise I need
strong slaves to build my country so I
have come up with a new health plan are
you ready yes very simple eat well or
I'll throw you in the mirror toss you
halfway across these will be able to
because you'll be in the mirin star I
have also noticed the education in
America is not very impressive I have
noticed that younger people are
struggling more and more so to make it
easy just get rid of school all you need
to know is one simple thing every time
someone asked you a question any
question just as all did it too
this great country you know ask a
question I can ask a question
lastly I think there should be a 24-hour
manhunt for the son of giraffe this man
must be stopped
however since it is going to take all of
our networks I'm going to call off the
search for Osama bin Laden you do you
not approve of this thank you the
sleeping bunnies in fact I think in in
the same person
the internet has indicated people I
would like all of you to be in those
other many people's republic of Houston
all you have to do is accept me as your
president there will be no moaning to
success if not there's a double sided
beer waiting for you and if there is
anything I want you to take from this
campaign it is one simple
now I would like you to all rise for the
Somme national anthem coincidentally is
our national anthem quiet coincidentally
the Tzar national anthem is exactly the
same as the American national anthem
except you replace all the words result
here we go
thoughts on sawdust hard spots on
jean-georges on Zaher Zaher Zaher Zaher
because